what up space fam goes in here from
anime ever and I'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece story and
I gotta say this chapter is a game
changer it's huge huge we got sabo's
truth and fate revealed we got imusama
the king of the world make an appearance
and show their true Power by attacking
Luffy Reveals His dream to his crew and
much more so make sure to stay tuned for
This mind-blowing truly game-changing
chapter trailer parking with it and
smash that like button if you enjoy
watching these one piece reviews and
want to keep them coming be a smashing
Power King rather than passing Orochi
and YouTube will transfer over fireworks
straight from wano to your screen true
story make this the video subscribe if
you haven't already and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications where you will miss future
one piece videos and updates and now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all first off I just want
to say the colored cover of this week's
Shonen Jump is awesome it chose Luffy
with his new officially colored gear 5
form he notably has pinkish eyes here to
compliment the color of his second
Suzuki scar definitely one of my
favorite covers we've had so far and I
like how it marks the iconic moment he
awakened his fruit we got a great cover
spread too of all 10 straw hats and a
white bear with we stand for Liberty
written on its face the crew really
looks great here and Luffy's definitely
got the drip going on with the ankle
bracelets right there now to the chapter
that is called Luffy's dream so we come
back to something we've addressed many
times and circled back to in the story
we start with Luffy freaking out over
the news about Sabo and saying he would
never kill vivi's father even nearby
alligators are freaked out at his rage
and just so you know I have no idea what
the difference between alligators and
crocodiles is I just picked one but you
can correct me in the comments of their
crocodiles it should help the algorithm
anyways but the point is Luffy clearly
has more faith in Sabo than Dragon does
while Dragon was considering the
possibility that Sabo may have done it
Luffy says there's no way he'd do it in
a million years and even Robin agrees
although the contrast between her
calmness and Luffy's outrage is
hilarious she says she agrees with Luffy
and that the Revolutionary Army is a
against the world Nobles now regular
Kings we get a repeat of the news saying
the Revolutionary Army declares war on
Celestial dragons king cobra of alabasta
assassinated by revolutionary Chief of
Staff Sabo and his daughter princess
Vivi is missing now what's interesting
is how much Zorro here has to temper
Luffy even though Luffy is Captain Luffy
is irrational compared to zoro's
stoicness he says set course for
Alabaster right now while Zorro says
what good would that do when the Man's
dead and Vivi was last seen in Mary joa
and it's emphasized just how irrational
Luffy can be here as he quickly changes
his mind and says then let's go to Mary
joa which is as Zoro explains the den of
the enemy Luffy calls her chicken while
Zoro says he just means they don't have
any leads and should probably relax
until they do Sanji is great too as he
cries uncontrollably saying please be
safe to Vivi again love to see how Oda
fleshes out these characters and how
they each have their own unique response
to the news here the ones with a
personal connection to Vivi and her dad
are more emotional obviously here while
newcomers like jinbei are more calm
about it as he just comments that this
year's reverie was quite tumultuous
while Luffy Nami and Chopper are
freaking out saying they're gonna go
save Vivi it's Zorro again who acts as
the mouth of reason I wonder if this is
foreshadowing for the two budding heads
more seriously some point soon hopefully
not but clearly Zoro and Luffy have
clashing views at times and I wonder if
at some point they won't be able to
reconcile the situation so easily I'll
definitely be keeping an eye out for
that as we move forward here though
Zorro uses what Luffy said about Ace as
an example Luffy said before that Ace
has his own adventures and so he trusted
him to make his own way up until the
point where he actually needed help
however a part of me is thinking that's
not the best example because look how
that turned out obviously we don't want
Vivi sharing the same fate as Ace Zora's
point though is that Luffy shouldn't
underestimate Vivi since she can hold
her own in my view definitely an overly
optimistic statement considering the
strong characters out there he adds if
the opportunity presents itself then the
straw hats can pitch in and in the
meantime Luffy needs to have faith and
stop bellyaching to which Luffy responds
that Zorro can't stop them from worrying
Zorro is in the right here though and
it's one of the realities of becoming
such a powerful crew as they protect
more territories and gain more allies
they can't keep sailing back and forth
putting out fires whenever they pop up
the bigger they get it's more possible
that more issues will pop up at the same
time and they just won't be able to deal
with them all and if they try they'll
never be able to get the one piece then
vivi's closest friends insult Zorro and
Zoro only retorts to Sanji which is
hilarious when he says shut it forth I
love how that's become a thing so
quickly now and and I'm kind of curious
as to how that may change when the
bounties change and potentially sanji's
position changes as well we also see
Luffy saying there has to be some mix-up
to the news that buggy is a yonko
Luffy's Instinct was right about buggy
so Props to that but we come back to
Sabo who's definitely the focus of this
chapter as Luffy says he's definitely
innocent and just wants no one else to
have their freedoms taken the way he did
clearly they both value Freedom since we
know that's one of Luffy's main driving
forces as well as a kid Saba wanted to
see the world and write a book about it
while we get Luffy's dream again which
the straw hats haven't heard up to this
point a Sabo and him sworn oath and then
he said what he'd do again we don't hear
what he said just people's reactions and
everyone is impacted by it whether it's
shock laughter or amazement Usopp says
there is no way anyone can do that to
which Luffy just responds that he'll
have a shot if he becomes the king of
the Pirates Luffy is surprised he hasn't
told them already and points out that he
said it to a Sabo and Shanks only when
asked by Robin how they all reacted he
says they all laughed and some tears
rolled down shanks's face Luffy says
that's what he wants at the end of his
dream and since Oda blocked it out again
it clearly doesn't seem to be the one
where he said he wants his friends to be
able to eat as much as they want Aunt
when he fought against kaido so place
your bets in the comments again for what
you think his dream might be and keep in
mind that it's something that Usopp
thinks is impossible I think we all know
of the big world party Theory but I
wonder if I'll read another interesting
possibility in the comments of this
video I look forward to seeing your
thoughts and back to the crew I love to
see people's reactions jinbei cries and
laughs like Shanks Chopper is just odd
and thinks it is awesome and Nami says
it sure sounds like you meaning Luffy it
is pointed out that he needs to be
pirate king to even make the dream
possible so they'd better find the last
Pawn glyph Robin points out that they
have no clue where it is and on that
note we leave the straw hats completely
uncertain as to where they'll go next or
what they should do however keep in mind
the flashbacks Luffy just had with Sabo
for what's about to happen it looks like
the events we're about to read May well
influence Luffy's next moves we head
back to the transmission that was
intercepted earlier they find out that
Sabo is in Lulu see a kingdom a kingdom
that rebelled days ago the elders say
that Sabo is an unlucky man and that
this is fate clearly this does not bode
well for Sabo as dragon is awaiting
sabo's answer with a grim face Sabo says
as we all knew he would and dragon
should have known better that he wasn't
the one who killed Cobra surprise
surprise but he continues and as the
Marines said he is desperate here
because it appears he didn't even
prevent them from being able to trace
his location he says he was in marijua
and saw something unbelievable and the
people of that Kingdom start to see
something huge in the sky at this point
we're probably all thinking that the
Marines have the ancient weapon Uranus
named after the deity that personified
the sky we see imusama as saboist
frantically trying to get all the
information out he says it happened in
the throne room meanwhile imusama
crosses out Lucia from a map Sabo says
he thought that there was no king of the
world but the empty Throne wasn't empty
he saw dot dot dot and just then a giant
attack rains down from the sky
completely obliterating the island the
Marines rewrite history as they like to
do and say no information was
intercepted that day and that lulusia
never existed at all and this means that
Sabo is most likely dead I definitely
thought Oda wouldn't go there since he
already killed off Ace but it's hard to
believe he could survive this it's clear
imusama launched this attack and it
shows how insanely powerful they are
with their influence last time a brother
of Luffy's died we had a huge change in
Luffy and a Time skip so there's no
telling what will happen now and the
next chapter can't come out soon enough
if you ask me let me know your thoughts
on this is there anyone who believes
that Sam will survive that and let me
know how if you think so a part of me
wonders if his flame fruit could have
helped him in this situation to maybe
blend in with the explosion or something
but we definitely can't be sure one
thing is for sure though if Sabo did die
Luffy is about to go berserk and this
time time if this happens Zorro probably
won't be able to hold him back back to
the straw hats and it looks like they
are headed for a winter Island they see
a giant warm Eddy but it's going upwards
it looks like a sphere of water they're
about to run when Luffy notices someone
Trapped In The Water they can hear a
girl in distress Sora decides to cut the
sphere and Chopper is blown away only to
be caught by Luffy but then Luffy gets
Blown Away with chopper and the trapped
girl is revealed to be none other than
one of the worst generation jewelry
Bonnie who has a bounty of 320 million
the narrator tells us she's small and we
know she can change age for herself and
for others definitely an insane chapter
I'm very curious to see what happens
with Sabo king of the world imusama is
becoming more relevant and I look
forward to seeing what jewelry Bonnie is
going to bring to the story now imagine
the possibility Luffy hears news of Sabo
they decide it's time to approach
marijua and they use jewelry Bonnie to
get a forced power up slash time skip
since she could make them older and
closer to their Prime it's definitely
what comes to mind by introducing
someone with her powers now but we'll
see what happens channel the pirate king
with an ant smash that like button if
you enjoyed this one piece review and
want to see more like it be a smashing
Power King rather than passing Orochi
and YouTube will transfer over fireworks
straight from wano to your screen true
story make this the video you subscribe
and if you haven't already hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates let me know
what you thought of this chapter what
would you rate it out of 10 and lastly
while you wait for the next one piece
video or update to come out feel free to
check out my huge and growing one piece
playlist that includes videos on all the
Admirals mythical zones a new video
about mihawk's Shocking True power and
much more linked to that is in the
description and on screen right now and
until next time see ya Space Cowboys